[Musique]
merci à polo de prendre le temps avec
nous et de se retrouver ici dans une
reconstitution du bureau de julerman
qu'est-ce comment ça te parle alors
c'est une une ouverture à l'imaginaire
réunionné je sais pas si le bureau de J
ressemblait à ça mais on trouve tous les
éléments de de son univers un peu fou
onetrouve les euh B des des des objets
longtemps des cartes des des appareils
étranges une machine à écrire où il
écrivait ses textes c'est un univers que
je trouve moi très bon dessiné et c'est
parfait pour parler évoquer la dernière
BD que tu as réalisé avec TM 20 décembre
alors comment est venue cette idée de
faire cette BD là avec le thème depuis
plusieurs années soit ensemble soit
chacun de notre côté on essaie de de
faire par la band dessiné une sorte de
panorama historique de de la Réunion il
y a quand même le le point central de
notre histoire qui n'était pas évoqué on
tournait autour mais on le traitait pas
qui est le le 20 décembre 1948 qui est
l'abolition de l'esclavage et puis ben
finalement on à l'occasion d'une
résidence aux archives départementales
on s'est lancé là-dedans on a fait nos
recherches et on s'est dit allons-y on
va raconter ça et on va raconter ça par
le le regard d'un d'un personnage
historique qui est le moins
pourquoi vous avez fait ce choix
d'edemon Albus comme personnage central
qui découvre quand il est esclave à 12
ans comment polliniser la vanille c'est
le TZ qui utilisé partout dans le monde
encore aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire qu'il a
vraiment trouvé quelque chose une
technique une une idée scientifique qui
est qui est qui est extraordinaire et en
même temps il a un itinéraire de de vie
qui est un peu dramatique et qui donc
qui se prête beaucoup à la fiction parce
que il découvre ça à 12 ans pour autant
on le libère pas il devient libre comme
les autres esclaves au 20 décembre
précisément après l'abolition on
l'envoie en prison pour un petit larsin
qui l'a fait personne ne se soucie de
lui il y a vraiment un itinéire très
romanesque chez EDM Albus donc ça s
[Musique]
prête
et ce qui a été important pour vous
c'est de donner le point de vue des
esclaves oui on a une mononde qui un
esclave privilégié entre guillemets il
il est pas dans les champs en train de
de couper la canne ou des choses comme
ça il est un tout petit peu protégé par
par son maître mais on a aussi donc ben
les esclaves qui sont abrutis par le
travail et cetera on a son copain H qui
est un marron parce qu'il y a encore des
marrons en 1848 on a essayé d'avoir des
des esclaves qui se Révol
des esclaves qui qui rêvent d'un avenir
meilleur et cetera dans la BD vous
évoquez avec TM potéon et Antoine
Roussin c'est la naissance de la bande
destinée réunonnaise parce queensemble
ils font une une revue qui s'appelle la
lanterne magique dans cette revue il y a
du texte il y a des illustrations et il
y a une idée géniale c'est de faire une
succession de vignett avec du texte pour
raconter la tournée sur gariga au moment
de l'abolition donc c'est la naissance
de la bande des runionnaise on fait
partie des pionniers de la bande
dessinée potéon et Roussin surtout
potéon en l'occurrence il fait partie
des tout premiers auteurs de bande
dessinée donc c'est quand même génial
que ce soit à la Réunion et c'est nos
nos ancêtres
[Applaudissements]
symboliques d'ailleurs moi il y a une
phrase qui m'a marqué et qui qui fait
écho aujourd'hui en tout cas quand quand
je l'ai lu ces gens-là à part Paris ne
savent toujours rien des colonies on a
toujours l'impression que à Paris ils
savent pas toujours tout ce qui se passe
mer ça aujourd'hui
dans dans les fictions françaises bah
les outr mè existent pour ainsi dire pas
mais mais pas que les outr mèes d'une
manière générale pour le continent
africain complètement oublié et cetera
ben donc nous il faut qu'on aille à
l'assaut pour on est là on existe on est
une société réunionnaise qui qui était
marquée par la violence continuellement
et on réussit on a réussi à la la
dépasser alors je sais pas c'est ça la
résilience je sais pas mais enfin
peut-être que ça c'est c'est quelque
chose que qui peut
s'exporter si on réuss un truc ben
autant le autant l'utiliser quoi merci
beaucoup àolo je t'en prie
[Musique]
merci